imagine you're in Rome and you've made
your way to the Vatican Museums and
you've been shuffling down long
corridors past statues frescoes lots and
lots of stuff you're heading towards the
Sistine Chapel at last a long corridor a
stair and a door you're at the threshold
of the Sistine Chapel so what do you
expect it
soaring domes choirs of angels we don't
really have any of that there instead
you may ask yourself what do we have
well curtains up on the Sistine Chapel
and I mean literally you're surrounded
by painted curtains the original
decoration of this Chapel churches use
tapestries not just to keep out cold
during long masses but as a way to
represent the great theater of life the
human drama in which each one of us
plays the part is a great story a story
that encompasses the whole world and
that came to unfold in the three stages
of the painting in the Sistine Chapel
now this building started out as a space
for a small group of wealthy educated
Christian priests they prayed there they
elected their Pope there five hundred
years ago it was the ultimate
ecclesiastical man cave so you may ask
how can it be that today it attracts and
delights five million people a year from
all different backgrounds because in
that compressed space there was a
creative explosion ignited by the
electric excitement of new geopolitical
frontiers which set on fire
the ancient missionary tradition of the
church and produced one of the greatest
works of art in history now this
development took place as a great
evolution moving from the beginning of a
few elite and eventually able to speak
to audiences of people could come from
all over the world
this evolution took place in three
stages each one linked to a historical
circumstance the first one was rather
limited in scope it reflected the rather
parochial perspective the second one
took place after world views were
dramatically altered after Columbus's
historical voyage and the third when the
Age of Discovery was well underway and
the church rose to the challenge of
going global
the original decoration of this church
reflected a smaller world there were
busy scenes that told the stories of the
lives of Jesus and Moses reflecting the
development of the Jewish and Christian
people the man who commissioned this
Pope six as the fourth assembled a dream
team of florentine art including men
like Sandro Botticelli and the man who
had become Michelangelo's future
painting teacher Gilliland i''m these
men they blanketed the walls with a
frieze of pure color and in these
stories you'll notice familiar
landscapes the artists use in Roman
monuments or a Tuscan landscape to
render a faraway story something much
more familiar with the addition of
images of the Pope's friends and family
this was a perfect decoration for a
small court limited to the European
continent but in 1492 the new world was
discovered horizons were expanding and
this little 133 by 46 foot microcosm had
to expand as well and it did thanks to a
creative genius a visionary and an
awesome story
now the creative genius was Michelangelo
Buonarroti 33 years old when he was
tapped to decorate 12,000 square foot of
ceiling and the deck was stacked against
him he had trained in painting that had
left to pursue sculpture there were
angry patrons in Florence because he had
left a stack of incomplete commissions
lured to Rome by the prospect of a great
sculptural project and that project had
fallen through and he had been left with
a commission to paint 12 apostles
against a decorative background in the
Sistine Chapel ceiling which would look
like every other ceiling in Italy but
genius rose to the challenge in an age
when a man dared to sail across the
Atlantic Ocean Michelangelo dared to
chart new artistic waters he too would
tell a story no apostles but a story of
great beginnings the story of Genesis
not really an easy sell stories on the
ceiling how would you be able to read a
busy scene from 62 feet below the
painting technique that had been handed
on for 200 years in Florentine Studios
was not equipped for this kind of a
narrative but Michelangelo wasn't really
a painter and so he played to his
strengths instead of being accustomed to
filling space with busyness he took a
hammer and chisel and hacked away at a
piece of marble to reveal the figure
within Michelangelo was an essentialist
he would tell his story in massive
dynamic bodies this plan was embraced by
the larger-than-life pope julius ii a
man who was unafraid of Michelangelo's
brazen genius he was nephew to Pope
Sixtus the 4th and he had been steeped
in art for 30 years and he knew its
power and history's handed down the
moniker of the warrior pulpit this man's
legacy to the Vatican it wasn't
fortresses and artillery it was art he
left us the Raphael rooms the Sistine
Chapel he left st. Peter's Basilica as
well as an extraordinary collection of
greco-roman sculptures decidedly
unchristian works that would become the
seedbed of the world's first modern
museum the Vatican Museums Julius was a
man who envisioned a Vatican that would
be eternally relevant through grandeur
and through beauty and he was right the
encounter between these two giants
Michelangelo and Julius the second
that's what gave us the Sistine Chapel
Michelangelo was so committed to this
project that he succeeded in getting the
job done in three and a half years using
a skeleton crew and spending most of the
times hours on end reaching up above his
head to paint the stories on the ceiling
so let's look at this ceiling and see
storytelling gone global No
more familiar artistic references to the
world around you there's just space and
structure and energy a monumental
painted framework which opens on to nine
panels more driven by sculptural form
than painterly color and we stand in the
far end by the entrance far from the
altar and from the gated enclosure
intended for the clergy and we peer into
the distance looking for a beginning and
whether in scientific inquiry or in
orang biblical tradition we think in
terms of a primal spark Michelangelo
gave us an initial energy when he gave
us the separation of light and dark a
churning figure blurry in the distance
compressed into a tight space the next
figure looms larger and you see a figure
hurtling from one side to the next he
leaves in his wake the Sun the moon
vegetation Michelangelo didn't focus on
the stuff that was being created unlike
all the other artists he focused on the
act of creation and then the movement
stops like I say Zora in poetry in the
Creator hovers so what's he doing is he
creating land is he creating sea or is
he looking back over his handiwork the
universe and his treasures just like
Michelangelo must have looking back over
his work in the ceiling and proclaiming
it is good so now the scene is set and
you get to the culmination of creation
which is man
Adam leaps to the I it a light figure
against a dark background but looking
closer that leg is pretty languid on the
ground the arm is heavy on the knee Adam
lacks that interior spark that will
impel him to greatness that sparked is
about to be conferred by the Creator in
that finger which is one millimeter from
the hand of Adam it puts us at the edge
of our seats because we're one moment
from that contact through which that man
will discover his purpose leap up and
take his place at the pinnacle of
creation and
then Michelangelo threw a curveball who
is in that other arm Eve first woman no
she's not an afterthought she is part of
the plan she's always been in his mind
look at her so intimate with God that
her hand curls around his arm and for me
an American art historian from the 21st
century this was the moment that the
paintings spoke to me because I realized
that this representation of the human
drama was always about men and women so
much so that the dead center the heart
of the ceiling is the creation a woman
not Adam and the fact is that when you
see them together in the Garden of Eden
they fall together and together they're
proud posture turns into folded shape
you are at a critical juncture now in
the ceiling you are exactly at the point
where you and I can go no further into
the church the gated enclosure keeps us
out of the inner sanctum and we are cast
out much like Adam and Eve the remaining
scenes in the ceiling they mirror the
crowded chaos of the world around us you
have Noah and his ark and the flood you
have Noah he's making a sacrifice and a
covenant with God maybe he's the Savior
oh but no Noah's the one who grew grapes
invented wine got drunk and passed out
naked in his barn it is a curious way to
design the ceiling now starting out with
God creating light ending up with some
guy blind drunk in a barn and so
compared with Adam you might think
Michelangelo's making fun of us but he's
about to dispel the gloom by using those
bright colors right underneath Noah
emerald topaz scarlet on the prophet
zechariah zechariah foresees a light
coming from the east and we are turned
at this juncture to a new destination
with civils and prophets who will lead
us on a parade you have the heroes and
heroines who make safe the way and we
follow the mothers and fathers they are
the motors of this great human engine
driving it forward and now we're at the
keystone of the sealing the culmination
of the whole thing with a figure that
looks like he's about to fall out of his
space into our space encroaching our
space this
is the most important juncture past
meets present this figure Jonah who
spent three days in the belly of the
whale for the Christians as the symbol
of the renewal of humanity through
Jesus's sacrifice but for the multitudes
of visitors to that Museum from all
faiths who visit there every day he is
the moment that distant past encounters
and meets immediate reality all of this
brings us to the yawning archway of the
altar wall where we see Michelangelo's
Last Judgement painted in 1534 after the
world had changed again the Reformation
had splintered the church the Ottoman
Empire had made Islam a household word
and Magellan had found a route into the
Pacific Ocean
how is a 59 year old artist who has
never been any further than Venice going
to speak to this new world
Michelangelo chose to paint destiny that
universal desire common to all of us to
leave a legacy of excellence told in
terms of the Christian vision of the
Last Judgement the end of the world
Michelangelo gave you a series of
figures who are wearing these strikingly
beautiful bodies they no more covers no
more portraits except for a couple it's
a composition only out of bodies 391 no
2 alike unique like each and every one
of us they start in the lower corner
breaking away from the ground struggling
and trying to rise those who have risen
reach back to help others and in one
amazing vignette you have a black man
and a white man pulled up together in an
incredible vision of human unity in this
new world the lion's share of the space
goes to the winner's circle there you
find men and women completely nude like
athletes they are the ones who have
overcome adversity in Michelangelo's
vision of people who combat adversity
overcome obstacles they're just like
athletes so you have men and women
flexing and posing in this extraordinary
spotlight presiding over this assembly
as Jesus first a suffering man on the
cross now a glorious ruler in heaven and
as Michelangelo proved in his painting
hardship setbacks and obstacles they
don't limit excellence they fortune now
this does lead us to one odd thing this
is the Pope's private chapel in the best
way you can describe that is indeed a
stew of nudes the Michelangelo was
trying to use the only the best artistic
language the most universal artistic
language he could think of that of the
human body and so instead of showing in
a way of showing virtues such as
fortitude or self mastery he borrowed
from Julius the second wonderful
collection of sculptures in order to
show inner strength as external power
now one contemporary did write that the
chapel was too beautiful to not cause
controversy and so it did Michelangelo
soon found that thanks to the printing
press complains about the nudity spread
all over the place and soon his
masterpiece of human drama was labeled
pornography at which point he added two
more portraits one of the man who
criticized them a papal courtier and the
other one of himself as a dried-up husk
no athlete in the hands of a
long-suffering martyr the year he died
he saw several of these figures covered
over a triumph or trivial distractions
over his great exhortation to glory and
so now we stand in the here-and-now we
are caught in that space between
beginnings and endings in the great huge
totality of the human experience the
Sistine Chapel forces us to look around
as if it were a mirror Who am I in this
picture my one of the crowd
am I the drunk guy am i the athlete and
as we leave this haven of uplifting
beauty we are inspired to ask ourselves
life's biggest questions Who am I and
what role do I play in this great
theater of life thank you
[Applause]
laughs thank you is that we mentioned
this wall issue of pornography to many
nudes and to many daily life scenes and
improper things in the eyes of the time
but actually the story's bigger it's not
just touching up and covering up some of
the figures this work of art was almost
destroyed because of that the the effect
of the effect of the Last Judgement was
enormous the printing press made sure
that everybody saw it and so that's not
something that happened within a couple
of weeks it was something that happened
over the space of 20 years of editorials
and complaints saying to the church you
you can't possibly tell us how to live
our lives did you notice you have
pornography in the Pope's chapel and so
after complaints and insistence of
trying to get this work destroyed it was
finally the year that Michelangelo died
that the church finally found to
compromise a way to save the painting
and that was in putting up these extra
30 covers and that happens to be the
origin of fig leaf ink that's where it
all came about and it came about from a
church that was trying to save a work of
art not indeed deface or destroy this
what you just gave us is not the classic
tour that people get today man they go
to the sixth inch are not necessary it
is it is it's a statement it is the
experience of art today is encountering
problems too many people want to see
this there and the result is five
million people going through the tiny
door and experiencing it in a completely
different way that we just in the last
fifteen agree I think it's really nice
to be able to pause and look but also
realize even when you're in those days
with you know fun would be at 20:20
eight thousand people a day even those
days when you're in there with all those
other people look around you and think
how amazing it is that some painted
plaster from 500 years ago can still
draw all those people standing side by
side with you looking upwards with their
jaws drop they it's a great statement
about how beauty truly can speak to us
all through time and through geographic
space please that's it that's it
thank you